[Music]
there's been this connection right
between the the marine corps and lapd
for a long time right yes like parker
was it i mean there was a portrait park
it was before chief parker yeah it was
one of the most corrupt uh in the nation
it was the corrupt most corrupt uh
department
and uh finally it had to be revamped
they got taken over i think federally
and they brought in a marine corps
general to redesign lapd right even they
redesigned the badge and if you look at
the the
the uniform of los angeles police
officers it's the same cut as the marine
corps uniform
same thing it's almost all the same
thing and also the simplicity of the
marine corps uniform you don't have
patches
unless you're in swat or traffic
you don't have patches on our actual
wool uniforms so it's it was designed by
marine and then he handed it to chief
parker
and uh chief if you can believe it chief
parker
was used as a model for a tv show
and guess who it was was that it was
spock wow yeah
ronberry was a maria was uh sergeant in
southwest
and then he wrote star trek and
he couldn't have uh uh spock lead the
ship so he had to pick another character
which was with whitman shatner wow oh
it's just useless he's attractive
he's there i wouldn't think so but he's
a nerd do you still have a lot of
officers coming on the job coming out of
the marine corps there was a couple
years where is it
before
you know when we came on it was a lot of
it was a lot and after vietnam right i
mean there was this yeah oh yes
yeah so you still have a lot of uh if
you look at these guys
uh they still have the wrinkle pins yeah
naval pins so you have a lot of uh
pretty much jeff uh we're pretty much
the only one under the badge on the
lapel
uh the marines where they're on lapd
where a little ega eagle globe and some
army do too much horses but the marines
are
definitely you see all the marines
wearing the ega
and and would you say that in
the the the criteria for being a good
marine and also for being a good cop it
lives in it lives primarily in loyalty
uh dedication to do dedication
dedication duty uh one of the things you
don't separate
it's always faithful even in this
atmosphere
where um
my wife she's she's had enough
you know the stress
that was on her
and she goes if you get killed i don't
even think anybody will appreciate it
but that was her opinion and i don't
blame her and i hope
a lot of citizens who are this the
silent majority that back us
uh stop being silent
because if not we're going to lose all
these good young officers
uh that that are just going to take off
some like those 15 officers in south
central
yeah we can't afford to lose good cops
here we can well and i think i look and
this this is definitely the direction i
want to get into just uh piggybacking
just when you come on am i right
the academy is one thing
but to feel like you know what you're
sort of doing takes at least five years
so you have six months in the academy
a year on probation rookie status and
then you're off but after that it takes
what would you say will you feel no it's
proven it takes five years for an
officer become cost effective i mean if
you're ever going to have a relationship
to the community you have to spend time
in the community and then if you well
yeah i mean but the thing is that's why
in lapd when you do your probation in
one area they put you in a whole other
area
because you don't want someone that's
just in one community you want them to
be used to several communities i think
the best
division of work
pretty much here is hollywood because uh
everything's there
and
and then and everybody lives there it's
very diverse plus the taurus
is from everywhere in the world and so
you get everything
in hollywood and you become i think a
really really rounded officer to handle
the basics and as well as everything
else but that's well jeff and i ended up
in hollywood together and but is that
was that where you first where where was
the first place you started in l.a 77 77
77 and so so 77th and we're talking
we're talking what year 80 uh no 1990
1990. just explain to me what's what
what what 1990 la is like like that
those next 90s yeah just just explain to
me what that was like and then take me
through sort of your time on on on the
gang units well when i when i first well
after the academy and i was in 77th
you're you're not used to dealing with
actual civilians
in that capacity where they can actually
a lot of the criminals can take
advantage of you sometimes you don't
recognize the signs if something's about
to go upside down that's why these more
experienced officers what we call the
p3s the two stripe
will at least recognize okay he's not
seeing
this so
he'll take over from there new year's
eve
before we hit 1991
the training officer goes god damn it
and he starts speeding up and
i don't know what this guy is is up to
so
as he's turning the corners okay we're
about to get into a gunfight he goes on
their bridge
he gets out of the car and leans up
against the wall
and waits
you might want to get out of the car so
i get out of the car and i lean up
against the wall and we're like between
pillars
and next you know
he goes now
and it scared the [ __ ] out of me when
all he hears
gunfire gunfire everywhere i mean you
just hear it all go off for like a full
minute minute and a half and then people
are reloading and still firing up in the
air
and then next you know you hear
the rounds coming back down hitting the
cars breaking windshields
what the heck i've never even heard of
this
i mean this
i've never heard of this in the news and
that that sort of thing was my
introduction to but that one that went
all the way through the 90s because we
had a gun expression which we did
training for gun suppress and uh detail
for new year's and so we would sit on
some of the hot zones and we would hear
the fire and then move in
oh that was like 96 97 we've
it's very rare some will come out and
shoot in the air
so we were able to to we had like just
contingents of officers everywhere
that soon as the
the shooting starts radio cold starts
were out there and we're going to
confront whoever's shooting up in the
air now you both were crashed you both
were crashed in the early 90s uh
yeah i he worked hollywood crash i was
at hollywood i was working we started me
and this other
officer started a narcotics car and it's
it's a dying art right now it's called
uh it was called the hype car for a
hypodermic needle which was for heroin
but we called it the hype car and it was
arresting people for 11 550 which is
under influence of a stage one narcotic
which is heroin
methamphetamine cocaine
um you know stage one drugs that are
illegal there's no medical use for him
whatsoever so
um
you know and now i started one in the va
valley at van nuys but when we met i
started another one i got hit up by
captain dial
best than ever what made him what would
be her what made her oh
she was she was a good leader she was
even killed uh uh she was a great street
cop was she from the community uh no she
was from back east somewhere um but she
came out here and she was a street cop
everybody you connie dial everybody that
mentioned you her name you were like
you know she held her weight back then
you know she went to the academy where
uh you know she told me that they didn't
want women on the job so they really
women that came on back then really went
through a lot and she came on once again
with the desire i'm gonna show these
guys and she worked
phenomenally uh she worked undercover
and uh she would have a great person to
get on to talk to yeah because i don't
want to give her
background because your mouth would drop
yeah her background
and so interesting when i left i mean i
retired
in october and uh it was just in time
for the election
and usually you would uh you would feel
like a whole weight when you retire you
feel like a weight's lifted off your
shoulders you gain years in your life
but
that's only partly so because when you
have
kids on the job
that that are still in the street taking
those risks
fighting fighting those fights trying to
help citizens
yeah you you kind of lose sleep at night
of course you know so no matter what uh
um
you just pray for them and you're
you're kind of like instead of crossing
over to retirement i got mine you know
moving on with your life you're still
there of course and so i remained as a
reserve
so i went from full pay cop to working
for free
and uh one of the reasons is the program
i work for
is a great program called pal police
activities league yep and man we help so
many families
you lose a few kids though and that's a
sad story we have one kid
we kept telling the parents you need to
move out of
our case manager
amy kept telling them you need to move
now why because the kid he unfortunately
his parents let these kids collect every
time i did search we we did search
warrants and we noted bob and i did
search warrants we did probation
searches parole searches and then we had
to do it with the juveniles because
every one of them had all the collection
of movies where it's a great recruitment
tool
blah uh
american me
uh scarface is the number one you see
scarface police sorry so you're saying
it's a recruitment tool it's a great
recruitment recruitment tool for who
for uh the gangs right that we're
working against and recruiting these
kids yep they didn't eat much with this
kid these kids are in a poor family both
parents are immigrants moms trying to do
the best she can from home
dad's working and they're struggling and
our pal program we we really try and
provide things for the family there's
only so much we can do you know all the
guys that we've we've spoken to you know
we were talking a bunch of the guys from
the pueblos and they all had very good
things to say about you and things about
the fact
a lot of it was the fact that you are
not only willing but that you you want
to communicate and that you you treat
people like human beings and and and and
i really want to get into that i guess
what i want to know you know what i just
want to reiterate um
just a quick story yeah well
i
arrested i don't know the number but a
lot hundreds of people found the
influence
it pays off in the end
and i'm at gold's gym at venice
and i see this guy staring at me tatted
up sleeved up
and he has devil horns tattooed on his
head and he's looking at me i'm like
man i better put some weight up today
yeah i mean
that ain't happening yeah so um i go to
a chess machine and he comes walking
towards me and i
so i do the nervous thing you kind of
look down but you see the two feet and i
look up and i'm like
and he goes hey are you deemer
and i oh
yes i'm deemer and he goes
broke right there and he goes oh man
well i you know what you arrested me
four times
and i go whoa uh i hope we're cool like
you know and he goes no we're cool
man
and he was telling me in the underworld
with me and my partner he goes you guys
are famous
and he goes you guys you got you got me
off
you got me off and i i and he got all
emotional and there's a guy with devil
horns like getting emotional and i i
said you know i was able to get up and
and it was weird from standoffish i got
my arm around this guy like you know i'm
like well i'm glad you're off you look
good you know and you know you look
solid and you got him sober yeah well he
attributes that and he was so happy to
see me because i guess maybe i was part
of this step to recovery and he goes can
i ask you for a favor
and i'm like
yeah
sure and he goes uh can you come to a
meeting with me well i went good for you
and uh i spoke
and it was unbelievable you showed up on
youtube date yeah day
but you do that i mean you do that man
and and i guess but i got something out
of it too
i was
we're not going to arrest our way out of
this problem we're not going to from
drugs to gangs
and you're not going to make it easy on
yourself if you don't have the ability
to communicate and talk to people and
find people interesting like we do jeff
and you know isn't it a step further
because what i what i see with you and
obviously i i see with you and how you
talk about your family and i can just
see it on you and and and you know you i
mean we've been friends for years but
you have this huge heart and you you
have empathy and i when we first rode
out and newton together i you and me are
out there we're talking to everybody
everyone you were like why are you
giving everybody your numbers yeah yeah
yeah
but but like i i did you know the guys
who i was speaking with the other day
you know uh and even i was talking to
some guys who who are active gang
members too and they all were you know
when you were brought up they talked
about how you went to the hospital there
was a young kid from cancer there and
how you went you you stayed with them
and you visited in their day after day
after day
[Music]
back